this is this is what I'm told is comedy
you may want to put your head on your
table right now
Governor Rhonda Sanchez ramped up his
war on Disney after they stopped his
attempts to control Disney World's
District here to comment is the villain
from the movie Aladdin Jafar
[Applause]
oh my God so this is the famous
Rockefeller Palace okay so Jafar as a
Disney character what do you think of
Ron DeSantis you mean the boy
the boy is an amateur he has no Riz no
spark no drip the look is giving baby
mayor
I mean he did wear those white cowboy
boots but let's be honest they were him
he might not look the part but are you
saying DeSantis isn't bad enough not at
all I don't get me wrong the boy is
plenty evil I mean Banning Rosa Parks in
schools I'm a dark sorcerer and even I
was like Jesus dude it's Rosa Parks
yeah now he's coming for Disney after
their stance against his don't say gay
bill
well from being gay that carpet has
flown you know what I mean
no I really don't
if you laughed at any of that never
watch this show again I want nothing to
do with you if you smile if your lips
moved smirk anything that's it you can't
watch anymore we're done of course it's
all nonsense right so don't say gay
drivel like all like what are these
people doing what are they doing with
their lives 30 people write that show at
least they have at least 30 writers that
spend a week to come up with that crap
but again who's the machine going after
who are they focused on they're focused
on the guy not running
DeSantis more than their focused on
Trump because as I predicted a year ago
they were going to turn to santis into
Trump I.E Hitler with the calculator
he's Trump but he's worse because he
knows what he's doing
[Music]
thank you